it's Monday morning I'm so excited I got
some good news and I got some bad news
give me the bad news what the bad news
first first let's start with that well
so I bought Priuses you know I retrieved
it right
oh well hold on let's listen to know
that you bought a Prius you lent it to a
guy you venema yet usually doesn't wear
a shirt and didn't have a car at 40
years old and he's like you know I'm
gonna leave it in the shady neighborhood
with the keys in it yeah well I go
inside and take care of some business
target's stalling bye bye yes bye a
crackhead and the reason I know it's a
crackhead is because I found crack pipes
under the seat okay okay that's fine
cleaned it out I guess somewhere along
the line it didn't get locked on the
street of Venice and well homeless man
took a little nappy-poo in his living it
oh dude [ __ ] in it no but he just took a
little nappy-poo
nothing wrong with that nothing wrong
with that Prius that's true the problem
is when you get into it I drove it here
i had to transport them the dogs exact
oh I got it back oh you didn't know I
got it back no the police god bless God
bless the LAPD I talked to a cop this
pressing issues more than well I stupid
prick I talked to a cop and I and he
said we'll get it back
and I said you'll get the car back how
and he goes if they didn't goes plate it
or bring it to a chop shop we'll get it
back flying down the street and they
found it in and in that day and because
apparently which I didn't know they run
plates yeah what so so they found that
wrong Hey found a runaway a good news
bad news crack pipes and a bum literally
[ __ ] all over I told you this probably
last podcast but I want to give a quick
shout out everybody I spoke to in the
police department everybody i spokes
probably Tim founder of ten people
including the detective all said this
this Rosen they go we're really sorry
this happened to you we hope you have a
better day it was a little thing made a
difference made a difference I
appreciate their professionalism so I
get it back cost me there's money there
it'd be better if they didn't return
what a good final insurance probably I
bring it back to Toyota they got to do
some stuff to it yeah clean it out if a
house it's definitely a scope it in
sores whatever all that all bums have
that all that I knows well there is a
homeless man sleeping in makar in the
back
yeah pretty comfy comfy and I'm a
compassionate man I'm a man well no but
I said hey but I can't use this safe at
home because some car what do you say
and he his eyebrows were I've seen him
before they are so long is that his
fingernails his eyebrows his eyebrows
are bushy beyond bushy bring up Brezhnev
bring up Leigh annoyed Brezhnev wanted
all of the pigs furry so they say hey
your cars here you go to pick it up the
bums in there sleeping yeah
and they say hey your cars on 9th and
rose yeah now see those eyebrows right
there oh those look like Kylie Jenner's
eyebrows compared to this guy's out
there to caterpillars yeah yeah so yeah
so did LA County go hey dude three cars
off ninth ninth and Rose go pick it up
yourself
no they tow it they tell it and how's
the bun sleep it oh no no this was after
I got it back this i-i've had it back
now I've had my car back for a while
okay so so it was out parked in front of
my house online in Venice unlocked and
as you know Venice has a bit of a
homeless problem California does yeah so
he was in the car he looked at me and he
goes well my name is Billy and I said
well I bill let's do yeah but I can't
have you stay or are you over 40
here's your name Robert Markle names
Robert we're not calling you Bill
anymore that's the least cute is no
Bobby Robert right but he's older older
man and I believe not a drug addict he's
a straight-up wino a straight-up booze
lessees wine yes
now now a defier gin it when I tell you
that it smelled like an open I'm all due
respect he just hadn't had a chance to
shower but it smelled like an open grave
and I had to drive here and with the
windows open
oh it's a little body odor and the oil
sucked into that unbelievable it's not
leather it's a Prius there's no leather
it's it's knit cloth see it's it's it's
actually um leather but that the faux
like yeah the foam attic leather we just
let it down
yeah rector so athletic look there you
go yeah faux leather so his body odor
just soaked it okay into that that's not
easy to get rid of now did you show them
the header
straight in the face I slew him I slowed
my cholesterol i corroded him III said
Shh I took some piano wire and I said
Shh you had better luck next next life
and that's the goodness that's the good
okay it's been laid to rest no the good
news good news is you pronounced miss so
god bless him god bless him even coat
your car's covered I gave him some water
I gave him some mortar because you
haven't gone you gotta hate water I go
I'll get you some water I got him some
water I'm a nice guy well no if you're a
nice your game wine I'm sorry you gave
him some wine I would have given this 41
that's that's true oh you see this will
play this in a little bit all right
that's [ __ ] the way that's hilarious
um the good news is I made an
appointment with dr. diamond to have my
lids looked at Oh
done yeah pop was getting it done we're
gonna consult listen you're fired -
we've only done how many podcast 700 for
you well that was from Jeff that was a
random call from Alabama so who knows
what it is
either way um so I was getting his money
right now I heard could you a done
speaker and they went okay we're seeing
a positive $1,000 can we get your eyes
yeah and Papa paid it papa
at least a little bit papa pay well
here's the thing that goes toward the
operation if I decide to go what you're
gonna do well now I'm you're kicking the
tires around now blowing nose we kick
the tires you're gonna come back and buy
the car kick the tires right
everyone knows and I you saw me kick the
tires so I kicked the tires of those old
eyelids that's like a hound up and then
I said to you I said I said to Brenda
and I go well I mean if I need it
and you went you need it you need it you
need it I hate I hate do this I got good
news and bad news for you now don't be a
dick I'm not being okay be nice I'm
being super this Monday I'm proud of you
for finally gonna die okay Javadoc we
don't know if I'm gay you donít show dr.
diamond not your real name whatever okay
is the thing yeah the good news is you
have money to get your lids done that's
the good news that's such good news yeah
yeah the bad news is you still owe me a
lot of money
why do you say when I know you're doing
elective surgeries I know you got my
money and then here's the worst news the
juice is running now hold on and now if
you wanna yeah he's a big the bigs
running yeah dude and if you charge me
interest yeah
know this bro you're a sick boy you're
you have a sick boy Empire that's not
your concern
that has nothing dude give you can wet
my beak illusions no what no otherwise I
got to start spilling the beans only wet
beaker gonna get it some surf and the
turf well a juice is runny and when I
know papa has the extra cash yeah take
care of his lids yeah your shoes [ __ ]
up the cash today action smooth now hold
on action smooth I've been rolling
action through probably and it doesn't
hold on no I like action supposed to but
Jackson smooth listen you have an empire
now I've had in him okay now hold on and
I feel like since I have I have things
you need right like I have for example
tell me I have information oh sure sure
yeah like the CIA yeah and you're a
leaky bird um well I can get a ladybird
bird right now I keep my vault
I keep everything is in the vault but I
can just spread rumors about you you
could I could you can I would never
follow you do that you wonder you know
what you became my beak well I keep your
beat a little wet wet yeah yeah no it's
not that you don't have that's the city
that's the thing so it's me to my ball
rock [ __ ] my volt skin my multicon itchy
hey what do you mean really put another
lock on that ball okay what are you
doing you know what I use my screws what
you can't turn that back on me it's
[ __ ] Mets you get greedy dude wait
we're brothers we're brothers with
others and my blood all J brother I only
call him buddy is it I talked to him how
drunk is J to go to Houston I can't wait
I can't believe in a restaurant we're
gonna eat in a restaurant that's a big
deal to my goat can we start you off
with some appetizers some beverages ah
ah ah what and you don't have a mask on
it's gonna be weird it's gonna be um oh
hey and I've been preaching from the
high top that we should open up a little
nervous yeah I mean that's it's okay
that's why I wanted you to come do it
yeah you can get your beak wet before
you go to Spokane right oh no stage job
figure stage I'm fine I'm nervous about
being in public in the mask and
coronavirus
I don't want to die that's fair we're
not doing a mean greets I guess on I
would lick everybody's face at the venue
I'm just kidding you guys I don't give a
[ __ ] yeah
fly on the plane and stuff should be
interesting yeah
how about today LA governor Newsom three
days ago no sports we're probably not
looking at any sports - I'm 21
all la sportsmen okay cool so we're
looking at Arizona in Florida man all
right now just hold on and today just
announced now so sports are back not
fans okay don't take all your money
where's all that [ __ ] you're talking
dude where's all that [ __ ] yeah Oh
sports bringing money to the state well
you know for everything else weird
sports aren't leaving early after you
and I and Joe and Eddie went bad on the
whole situation and we're we were calm
pontificating and recog are said yeah I
was six whisky wsd Oh Brendan by the end
I smoked weed by the end of it Brennan I
looked at him and I went well you look
pale and you're sweating I think he
because I don't feel what didn't eat I'd
nicotine yeah I'd create them yeah I had
a lot of cheese I'd candy I had a
shitload of whiskey yeah and then I
drank or and I smoke weed yes am i there
not by then I was like kind of seeing
double
yeah you're in a lot of it well I just
was sick my Stokes they didn't eat and
they need all that [ __ ] and drink
and smoke
you gotta get tiny how crunk were a
great time a great time after our thing
I went and talked to a woman who knows
local politics she knows how I saw it
takes she ran for she works I ran for
Congress okay so so wait hold on what
give me a where'd you meet her
give me she's a friend of my sister's
okay and so yeah and she she didn't win
but she but but it was funny because I
have all my ideas you know about
politics and she goes it was so funny
it's like a joker I was like a guy she's
she's a she's essentially she's a
Republican but I think she's more of a
pro-choice she's black she's from
Jamaica and she she just Los Angeles and
and California's has such a super
majority of Democrats it's all that
class that even if you remember if you
register as a Republican I'm not a
Republican I'm approached where
I got I'm too much of a libertarian but
if you register as Republican as in this
business you can get blackballed right
so there are a lot of closeted
Republicans there are a lot of people in
this town it's like being California's
like being gay in the 90s yes
Californians basically vote primarily
concerned in a very conservative way
actually they're pretty conservative
let's go to Orange County
they're pretty Republic yeah that that's
right yeah but even in LA like a lot of
like wealthy a lot of actors are under
there they're kind of hidden there are
these they're apparently these
Republican speakeasies there's there's
these groups that mean blah blah blah
I'm not not I'm just not committed
politically as I'm not a Republican I'm
more of a libertarian but so I can't get
with that but what about this Jamaica
but it was so much time to talk to her
about how [ __ ] actually gets done and
how you like what an uphill battle you
have you take all the energy out of your
body when you realize how hard it is of
course I did because it'd be like I felt
like a kid who's watched kung fu movies
and Bruce Lee movies talking to and it
to a bunch of MMA guys who've been
veterans like you know cowboy Cerrone
and anti pettersen and I don't know but
you know I'm saying and same to them
dude if you watch Enter the Dragon why
don't you guys do the wheel kick and
then you could fight for and they would
be like I literally I felt that naive
about politics well if you're not balls
deep and yeah like you know what you
give it yeah so so will you do it so big
Union and I'm in a union so I'm not
saying anything but but big Union says
two billion dollars to their candidates
so if you're not for the Union so so if
you're not gonna create jobs for union
members you're not getting elected
you're gonna have a tough time getting a
lot yeah so there are a lot of things
that politicians that are very surprised
by the no but the nitty-gritty and the
details
don't [ __ ] anything changed or lols it's
a you got a play ball I can't imagine
you got a play ball yeah they're all
scum and all of a say we do one thing
until we got there and we realized oh
well I have to do this because I'm not
gonna you know their deals you make
along the way it's such a it's such a
it's such a dirty game it's such a dirty
game it's amazing anything gets done
because the people that do vote in local
election
are none of us cuz I don't know anything
about local who do you know your
counselors I know your la casa no my
you--some is cuz you here in my life
do you know Mike Baumann no he's
probably the reason that we have an
homeless issue one of the reasons his
his ideas of he was like if people
foreclosed in their houses and if hotels
go belly-up over this will put homeless
people in there that's what he said
like with kind of like a and excited I
you know so if you don't know that and
if you don't know but you know votes for
all these people
unions people have something like those
teachers all you the people that so so
it's it's it's an interesting it's a
very different thing they're very
different so I kind of felt very nice
but but I I think to your point that's
why a lot of young people don't vote
because they don't think it's gonna
change anything things are just gonna be
this a yeah and it won't be like vote it
matters yeah well this was this woman
said on in November vote brush up on
your local politics on your City
Councilman or what they stand for and
vote if you don't you will always be
taken you will always be at the whim of
powerful forces like big Union and other
come that have a lot of stake bubble we
don't be letting things yeah I'm gonna
be anyway yeah but you can but look I
mean there are ways to change there are
there you know there are ways to do a
grassroots thing and you leave that
Republicans that one Mike Garcia I mean
he was a business huge Air Force pilot a
business yeah so there are ways to to
now what did you say bug in your lips
done now not my lips my lips are there
you live in this little it's watch lid
lips why would I get my lids literally
have an upper lip I have beautiful
sultry bottom lips fantastic I have a
nice upper lip is a little gun are you
[ __ ] kidding you know that's because
I have a mustache no I if I was gone all
right the whole my upper lip is like a
whole lot don't be a tech watch let me
just be relaxed with my mouth right nope
not really there your bottom ones pop in
papa
thanks buddy it's a fun thing to kiss my
bottom is a nice nice hunk on that
bottom lip yeah dude how much you think
I take off the top lids there your
visors your skin well it can't be much
because I got it I can't have people
I've gone on a TV show I can't look on a
wait a minute sighs did I say something
and I I hope it does
that happened if it does gonna be
fantastic for everybody involved if they
take too much
no no brain is stuck Brennan goes like
this and you just always look surprised
oh my god would it be fun though no I
couldn't blame your friends it'd be fun
I couldn't blame have you seen this
video speaking of no what is it
this is the bomb in your car no wait was
for the place of you can I just say some
real quick yeah I got a brand new iPhone
Pro 11 max whatever ad for rapaho so you
remember out my phone went off last week
and then today yes there's a first time
out of breast you ever strike so last
week Dave Rubin had a heart out so I
said alarm okay turn all the way down
apparently the alarm doesn't turn all
the way down because I'm alarm no this
is this new phone can do no work today
try to send this video and then the
video went off when I was sending it cuz
you're not used to it yeah that's all
the phone it's a cool thing that's gonna
slap you if it goes this is kind of a
nice break
what is this I don't know Brian see
let's change the Olesya B oh did you
send it to me oh yeah I just thought it
was no and you're driving your buddies
keep texting you know how they call it
get to it yeah that's why I haven't
gotten to it well some you me and Rogan
we have a threat and it's like all [ __ ]
you should definitely click on yeah but
when I'm driving my garlic get to it
then I forget ya and I'll send something
wrong like can't you [ __ ] see why
centering oh yeah my bad yeah all right
here we go hey man
how much how much how much do it for 40
bucks per person do why sorry do all hi
you know I'll suck both you guys off for
40 bucks or ask about weed what what is
that that Jonah Hill it looked like a
messiah no it's not him
what was that be well again it's just
driving how much how much how much do it
for 40 bucks per person do why sorry do
all high you know I'll suck both you
guys off for 40 bucks
all right we're asked about weed no I
don't know what what's going on I'm
confused too
how much and the guy goes what [ __ ]
how much he goes 40 bucks 40 bucks but
first I'll suck you both off boy bucks
person and they were like no we were
talking about weed yeah do you know him
no somebody sent that oh poor guy this
is real oh yeah let's block it let's
let's blur his face I thought that was
viral all right didn't any smother his
friend or didn't Eddie send that to us
all right let's edit that out
well you gotta leave it now and
fantastic know you people got no over
talking about it was terrible bright oh
I'm sent that to me he was a so why did
you do that to us
explain yourself that was funny
you thought that was funny if we knew
him it'd be funny
feels like South so we go yeah and I
said well where is this that was Jonah
Hill had been funny
it looks like Johnny L it does a little
bit hey hey that's not the video I was
gonna have you sent anyway it be you're
better than this
I thought it was no comedy I thought it
was funny yeah maybe in the text that it
is funny cuz but Boris can be plural of
course yeah we got to leave it cos
friend I want fans
to realize what I went through right now
why is that so bad they just you know
that's that's it this stuff we talk
about all the time I know but we don't
know him that happens all the time I
think what I mean it happens all the
time you know where they were dry by the
way that's a video Brian said to me like
on last week but we never got to play it
that's why I sent it over I know all
right yeah because he had honey you send
this video he doesn't watch this one no
we're not not on that if I'd cast this
one okay I mean it's it's like heartfelt
and the guy put bagpipe music to it and
he put like and and they were I did a
cameo for this guy who was a you're
still in cameo yeah I do it all the time
but it's what everyone yeah sure but I
make a lot of money on it um no but I it
so so if I have something I want to give
money to it's yeah or pay you or pay my
bills um for the eyelid surgery which
I'll never do it but listen I'll never
pay for that that way but um this guy
made this video yeah and you'll watch it
later and I was watching it and I was
like and he put back pie yet plate now
we're gonna play please redeem yourself
no just watch it no because we know we
everyone hate you right now this can be
so much better I did this you're a
retired the shortest man in the military
the shortest man to ever serve in the
military
don't laugh and I'm not laughing and he
was a green beret in Vietnam he's four
foot by four foot nine for nine Green
Beret and he died this is he died he
became homeless
he served in one like all these medals
and he said Vietnam in Vietnam any any
any passed away five years ago
but he died homeless he was homeless and
so this cop this awesome police officer
who I think was also a green beret I
said I want you to do this I want you to
do a cameo for this guy kind of say some
words for him here's and I researched
him I looked him up and I went and he
wanted me to kind of do a eulogy for my
guests did they play it at his funeral I
know I think they did I think they
planned I didn't realize I iced died in
real this dude put it to music and to a
collage and you know you forget I was
doing it I I did feel some film in a
while ago about about a week ago though
a little bit but I felt when I read
about this guy was really inspired and I
just kind of stood
spoke from my heart and off-the-cuff and
this dude made this video and I found it
so moving even though it was my own
words it's not why I was doing it but
when you put bagpipes do you have
pictures of his bagpipes on anything
right it's good oh so Watson
it was called stopping stop you can't it
doesn't I stopped trying to do this and
we add the weight this is the Bobbie Lee
situation we gotta wait no I'm good I
swear to god I'm good rest in peace go
back you know it's weird is the other
soldiers will the tallest I know why
they do that so why are he was he was
the shortest man I've ever saw in the
military it's actually in a saying
what's insane is not there is 4/7 the
melted if they use a green beret no it's
nuts
and they say you swim across through the
tunnels yeah Brian it's condos the
Vietcong it's the Vietcong wife is he's
smaller I got a system of tunnels I know
all right so they would send him in
because well of course you would why
women you're not going in I can't pin
the devil he's going in he's any [ __ ]
the bats dude he's the best at it I know
the best yes but it is play-action
it is pretty awesome and pretty moving
and a bunch of green brace chip to him
being brave money we gonna they bought a
headstone they bought him a headstone
hall and they gave him a proper burial
they don't know it's a very sad story
sir said yeah rewind it so you can see
it all right the whole thing here who
was the smallest was a green beret in
Vietnam what a brave dude you know I
guess he was 4 9 97 pounds smart doesn't
round got a Silver Star two Bronze Stars
two Purple Hearts well
fifth year he's been God he was homeless
oh I think about these things we're all
lucky that we don't fall through the
cracks
all of us can I don't give a [ __ ] who
you are Monica how good you are I don't
care how hard you worked
I don't care there go us by the grace of
God that's what I say I mean you start
taking credit for your success
for your health for anything you better
be careful
[Music]
there's heartbeat in a heartbeat you
know so I I read stories like this and
it fills me with compassion and it
reminds me of never to judge and it
reminds me to stay humble and it reminds
me not to think of myself in any way
it's better than anybody else and that's
you know better has no children no no
someone like him reminds me of that I
just just blew the stuff that I read
pictures I saw dude I can't believe it
this is better than the Rudy know this
guy know Rudy was offside make a movie
about he's played this guy fought for
your freedom and but to them to the
bagpipes sounds like I've written this
like I'm doing it sounds like it's a
movie like I'm marrying a movie what
sounds I just thought well I am oh yeah
I'm I was just doing in the Vietnam War
I said I'm glad I wasn't no where were
you during the draft not born yet you
were born in the 70s do you mind I was
born in 1967 I was a little baby okay
like you know I'm sorry any blank you
for stopping figured draft-dodger
I've never seen you laugh so hard I'm so
sorry when I get the gills I can't stop
the problems we're not supposed to laugh
yeah yeah it's so he tell me not to and
then you don't then you're like yeah
he's small and then they show the video
and he's forced that well it wasn't
ready
because it's astonishing it's amazing
what he was a baby and he was he was
Rudy get a movie I know and this guy
does it I know
and then just died homeless you know
anyway I'm watching this as this guy's
putting bagpipes to it and it sounds
like I wrote this morning by yourself is
like super I got emotional in here night
my own words in here not so much with
the three of us but in here not so much
because we're you're all dead behind the
ice and you're not American there's oh
there's a I was so humble it looks like
a child
yeah that's with all these soldiers and
was a green product in one picture they
have him at the deli at the counter with
that with that cop it sound nuts and
then and then he what a stud yeah yeah
look at that and they just became their
holy still Wow that's come on come on is
that crazy or how much harder is for him
when they're running in and let me tell
his jungle Vietnam and the Green Berets
went through some [ __ ] in Vietnam oh I
mean in the Vietcong jeez yeah I mean it
wasn't they were our Special Forces they
were you know I mean I it's just uh
Richard a flatter flatter celerity
Flaherty and Irish ability yeah captain
captain
and then just became the the the
homeless things above yeah and forgotten
and forgotten until this one I wish I
could no I'm I wish I could give a
shout-out to the police officer because
I think he was a green beret or
something like that and Eddie said that
to me Eddie sent it to me no no right in
how about there it is that's crazy him
at the deli there but how about Eddie
made barstool sports he did yeah it said
Eddie gives one of the most you know
great performances on fight companion
okay hey by the way the cops name is
David usek and he took his time out of
he paid for and everything to this time
to give this guy's Center so shout out
to yeah Miami cop David music Bank man
you're a good man should we play this is
cool well yeah I see that
okay wait Eric Anders by the way I'm not
sure what this is
oh there's team lockdown team freedom
there's only two teams play it
the Campania and this awesome decision
the other haircut both work James
there's all this team locked down and
there's team freedom there's only two
teams Facebook Facebook took that and we
barely watch it the old guy what I'm
saying is um if I would have told you
that a year ago I said there's gonna be
if I woulda said there's gonna be a
great if this impeachment if this
impeachment fails they're gonna come
hard with that look it's hope let me
stop you
it's not you're gone let's just say I'm
goin hard my conspiratorial
what if I don't know these are just
conclusions don't make fun of me but
that's a fun time that was a great time
[ __ ] you
they got video of you grabbing your hats
me oh I was stuck because my my balls I
was gonna say something wrong doing it I
knew I was on camera my balls were stuck
under my [ __ ] anything
I literally had my balls were stuck
under my body and I was like [ __ ] my
old balls I didn't care I knew I was on
camera yeah [ __ ] you do I got my balls
stuck in all this it's so hard what do
you know everybody's listening so we
have to be a little careful with what we
say right it's like why no I'm just
saying you know why would you talk to
some time oh that's is this it I don't
know if those what if that's real that's
beautiful but my conspiratorial mind but
this would be a great idea for Team
vodka
this one's a stress a lot of lis saying
that I agree with
okay told opposition be a rebel and say
you can open up your plan and then we
sacred [ __ ] up pals and Corona deaths
and then we restart the lockdown because
and then now everyone's afraid to I look
the oldest that's where you can surgery
I gotta well I got to dye my beard I
don't know you don't look right now I
look cute you look so cute thank you
love the right cat I love cat all I care
about is what women like cat say yeah
you guys are fast and two women tidy
your lids done no no my my mother
no the the it gets worse worse in my
family it's hereditary so I will you
will not see my eyes in a couple years
here be cool so my mom and the people on
that side of family get it done so did
your mom get it done but when I get it
done I'm gonna come back and I'm gonna
see if you noticed let's see there's a
screen shot that's awesome
that's funny yeah I know there was an
aerial shot but I was like my [ __ ]
[ __ ] on them I was like let me pull
these bad boys down yeah a bunch of
people set screen shots to fight or the
kid yeah brother
what's great about I spread yes i day
but what's great about that whole
situation is that I just you just don't
give a [ __ ] right it's like what I was
gonna leave and throw up hey are they
allowed to I mean I wonder if people can
see when you're texting if they can see
your phone number or what you're texting
if you're if you're if you're out in the
open with it they can and if they
resolution on the cameras good enough
they could zoom in so just be careful
not to like
I've never seen anything gonna be so
hard though he cares it'd be tough to
see a really tough you never know
they'll appease some people are pretty
good but definitely I said don't send
dick pics don't what don't text on the
open like that even here I would just
say like turn your phone upside down if
you don't want people to see if people
have my number you could do it like this
though yeah they can't see it right if
it's laying on the table what you guys
never do though yeah doesn't matter um
anyway yeah I think you're right I never
thought there should be a movie about
that the smallest guy in the military
I'd watch the Steven Spielberg would
make that movie a 4-foot who would play
the character Steven private dirty yeah
who would play that who would play that
fine an actor who's that small you'd
have to find a legit oh that's English
Oh a different kind of the eaglets isn't
athletic enough to be a green beret you
need a small man you basically need
somebody who's totally proportioned okay
you do you need so yeah you can't have a
small person cuz they're not gonna have
them yeah that's that's a dwarf there's
a dwarf is what cereal gives uh your
your boy didn't have dwarfism here's the
small person right he's a small person
so dwarfism is different that comes with
were for the dwarfs can't be or small
people can't be in the special it's very
I don't think they can run their talents
there's many issues yeah but and also
their asses fit in the pants all that
stuff dude but that guy you you've got
to be is that is that it's an article on
military.com biller a four-foot 14
inches dude do they have a picture if
I'm the giant killer they're just that's
him right there and then uh Dan that's
not we can play this think about that
for a second want to see it go hey if
you want to if you want to ship stuff
and you want it done right and you got a
station that ship yeah well if you're if
you're working with Amazon or Etsy or
your own website ship station o-rings
all your orders into one simple
interface dude help online sellers of
any size get orders out quickly saves
money on shipping costs and you keep
your customers happy you can manage it
from one device including your cell
phones
yes USPS FedEx Amazon Fulfillment you
you can you can work with all major
characters no one ship station number
one choice of online sellers and right
now the final kid listeners can try ship
station free free free free free days
when use the offer code fighter make
sure your business is ready to meet the
demands of delivery culture get started
ship station calm today take on the
might from the top of the homepage and
type in fighter
that's ship station calm then enter
offer code fighter I believe Brennan
shop that we use this
I'll check with Jeff yes so it's a very
very good it's a very good company ship
station not much easier make ship happen
yes I like I like some of my new glasses
stupid I like I like apparel I like
wearing apparel I like I'm an athlete I
like you in a pair of cuz I don't want
to see you naked I understand and now
you have no reason because on it for
this week only is 50% off apparel this
week only Monday through Sunday 50% off
men's t-shirts women's apparel men's
promoting wearing leggings your girl
doesn't want some leg in shorts and
pants got no more excuse not to buy your
girl something 50% off summer apparel
they got Black Swan yoga apparel Lobby
Marcus stuff prime acts acts jiu-jitsu
MMA gear everything 50% off get it now
go to audit comps last fighter tips off
all the supplements and nutrition but
then you get fit yourself apparel what
else do you want from us I mean if you
work your body out and you put good
things to your body you got it you got a
deck it out in good threads don't you
exact get out yeah the whole thing I'm
telling you they're gonna make a movie
about this I don't know if that was
really makes it but he certainly didn't
show any plows and he shot all those
people down what had happened when the
River Walk and I think it was in what we
called the a quick bill at that time so
it's long a thousand-meter village that
rent where the river running through it
and it was a known area where you're
gonna get contact you never went in the
a click bill without running into the
end for some reason they just kept
coming back there
and so we're doing a sweep and my unit
had jumped some North Vietnamese and
Vietcong on one side of the river and we
shot several of them but they did not
they weren't dead and I was gonna call
for a medevac helicopter you know a dust
off so you get him out of there so
because I had the medics work on him and
you know look like okay well there
abouts tables are gonna get and so I'm
radio over to Richard and I said I've
got to Victor Charlie WIA and he said
Roger to Victor Charlie ki a and I said
no no WIA I said so winter via whiskey
India alpha and he says no he kept
coming back with the ki a and I knew
what he was saying because he was saying
basically what let's just move on kill
them let's just go Wow and I had guys my
platoon der looking at me going yeah we
don't want to do this I'll tell you
that's it so Miami police officer David
music befriended a homeless man after 15
years of friendship Richard J Flaherty
finally revealed who he was music learns
that this unassuming 69 year old man was
a decorated military veteran so that
that's shout-out to Miami police officer
David you so cooler T is killed by a
hit-and-run driver and he was hit by a
hit yeah killed by a hit-and-run driver
he did time in prison for drugs yeah I'm
sure you know yeah all right inter than
fiction tales that would never make it
as a movie peach movie pitch because
it's so unbelievable so kind of a movie
here it's called the Giant Killer I'm
sorry they kind of did like a
documentary movie called the Giant
Killer like it's on iTunes in okay
Amazon huh
well there you go okay the Giant Killer
then also him doing time in prison for
drugs they don't know if it's just a
cover cuz he did someone to cover work
of his a real can power a lot time
fooled there a lot time fault really
really interesting man that's crazy
four foot nine crazy yeah
oh I got the Giant Killer yeah man dan
was hit by a car that sucks
his story's crazy it's definitely a
movie worthy story I think it isn't
movie where the story yeah I hope they
optioned it may be a good idea I'm gonna
send that to uh joe carnahan and frank
grillo that's the kind of movie they
write oh yeah who's the actor who's the
shortest actor in Hollywood there's this
there's a small as our I like who's the
the guy that played John Lent no John
you know could play it Breckin Meyer
Britton Meyer is that my buddy an IRA
man SIA reckons 5-4 it's still too tall
it's a little too tall but you could get
tall actors around hole soldiers and
widths with CGI now you can do all kinds
of weird [ __ ] I guarantee there's a guy
who's four four four seven or four nine
where the [ __ ] you us who do it they're
out there this guy Taran Edgerton that
played Elton John I think about Elton
John how long for short I think he's
pretty short I don't think he's that
short though let's see five nine no
money never mind this short it's an
actor I can think of is that guy from
Hannah Montana Moises arias he's like
5-1 moist ah well you know short is that
guy Jon Snow okay oh yeah judge snows oh
he's five three he's [ __ ] five three
or is he five five that's it next time
though he's now that's him next to
Edgerton and he was five six yeah it
looks like he's probably around five six
oh and your boy has heels on there too
so yeah let me see a five five boy he's
a tiny fella John snow sprite five five
damn still too big dikembe mutombo
compared to four stuff yeah that's a
short guy Jon Snow
that's my my hate it nice shorter than
five eight we'll find someone we're out
there yeah yeah
Brendon shop let's plays the giant Danny
DeVito for town yeah Danny DeVito would
be Little Joe Pesci five four hold on I
say go back thank you yes would be great
oh yeah Thank You Venus he'd be great at
it
Bruno Mars uh he's not that short that's
really short Kevin Hart Scorsese is five
for Scott Caan's only five five yeah
he's timing Scott Caan so short Scorsese
short Jason Alexander Bruno Mars that
cliff would be great um go back for a
sec damn Dreyfuss is only five five Lucy
if woody I wanna do it yes cots for says
God's a super macho guy like he's it
yeah you know he's a white rapper
Scott Caan he's got it yeah is it used
in a straight legit rap group well hey
Theo sure that's James Caan yeah again
white rapper there's guys on five nine
I've worked with him Elijah Wood Elijah
Wood is tiny yeah all the hobbits are
Ralph they're small in general who James
make a boy go back the voice who Jon
Stewart it's awesome call it Culkin
Miller Sousa was called Culkin was so
small five seven Ben Stiller five seven
Tom Cruise five seven girl the actors
got the smaller actors are Al Pacino is
even smaller than that Johnny help us on
David's burger front is only five eight
yeah I thought he was actually smaller
for some reason yeah these are Hollywood
so you got to got about two inches Mark
Wahlberg is go back yeah he's short five
eight I don't even know if Mark Wahlberg
five eight yeah well you gotta remember
these guys have shoes are adding some
inches yeah
oh it should keep look I wrote anything
like five nine what yeah
yeah I thought Brad Pitt was a little
taller than 511
but he's my height I've never seen him
in person mm-hmm all right oh yeah good
luck with your movie dude I bet my
favorite is Brendan the first time he
was started hanging out in Hollywood we
were at this party with a lot of lottery
dot people you know and yeah you know
kind of some famous people and it was a
cool group and Brennan was still kind of
he was still fighting all these
musicians and actors and writers and and
I see Brennan standing there with his
legs really spread apart oh he's talking
he's trying to talk and he comes up to
me and he we're on a roof and he goes
hey I mean North oh yes all that party
dude I'm dude I mean hey relative went
to that screening and well your anger
doesn't suck am i right it was all oh my
god
- huge directors yeah that seemed better
here though and I definitely never say
like what do you think I'm moving seemed
better I mean just bigger than everybody
look like well no you don't mean like
that you mean like no no I mean I was
like no I definitely mean I've seen
better films than that huh just I don't
know how we're huge guy the first time
you barely tell me you got in a pool is
a pool party
nobody swims had a boy honey in Los
Angeles you [ __ ] Aurora mousse the
Aurora mousse is like cannonball you get
tens like and he's like look at my
shoulders got bad tattoos fangirl yoga
Scott he's so big no she goes oh he's so
big I got the water zone I started
eating the mini ham sandwiches along
whatever I know he used to be so fine
these two really hot famous girls I
won't say their names they're looking at
Brennan he had a hit a putt can take
that I'm wearing
Jelena takeaway in there
in Hungary I and the Giant and I go you
those girls are looking at you dude
because I know I know it's a curse and
he's got two slices of pizza and all my
favorites hmm
could I get a box a box I don't think
I'm fat and he puts it away like it like
a girl and then you who then you wait
until they left it order the apple pie
he's an apple pies the best now I've
embraced the thickness it was great I
have embraced the thing why you wouldn't
I'd be [ __ ] all over it it's all I've
ever wanted to be they liked you [ __ ]
funny thing are they open this GTA open
there should be a thing Joost is open
and they have that pie I would go right
now and get that [ __ ] apple pie god
damn it and they're those pecan cookies
yeah they [ __ ] do Brennan juices open
huh juices open dude just yeah that's
nice about there it is just yeah GJ yeah
let's our place our spot haven't been
that forever oh my god that's nice I
can't believe you're playing he's there
yet you sending me I can't wait I'm so
psyched - me too
I'm so excited it's work she's gonna be
on a road in a while I'm scared you only
my kiddos and just get out of it you
know oh yeah you've been this routine
for how long yeah put my son to bed
every night for 60 days straight
it's great yeah you and I have known
each other a long [ __ ] time dude yeah
it's so funny because well no matter
where we are no matter how many people
were around the one thing I'll say I've
probably never met anybody with the
exception of Jimmy Burke that I
fundamentally agree with on everything
on everything yeah you and Ike it will
gravity like you can look at me and I'll
look at you and I know exactly what
you're thinking like Razia [ __ ] one guy
came I was like you know that's it it
was great a little too cool and I just
like I think your brain is the greatest
literally like that's right we've just
been together every day every week and I
just I can look at you and I know and
it's we've always been that way we've
always been
and we're different in a lot of ways but
we're so similar in like what we
actually consider to be important I
guess the truth of a subject that's why
the show loves ya
how much fun we'll shoot it how we talk
do we talk about shooting on here no we
haven't been less oh yeah we went to
Terran tactical your boy did night
oh no you time eyeliner oh yeah I didn't
kill shot it dove I shot it up and Logan
Paul who who's a great guy yeah you you
uh you I was teaching Brandon to shoot
and I was like look see through that
right there that sight are you little
bored do you think I care less if I do
it this way he was like try and give me
time I like shooting like I would get
there I like doing all the stuff that I
do I'm like all right got it
yeah I can't be there for hours like
people like my girl could be there for
our yeah I was I when I met you
how old was I there 47 we get you're
here that's up Fox damn I was not as
gray as I am now but I notice that Fox
were weird huh yeah they were that's
when we did that that hilarious
self-defense thing yeah it's been a hot
second yeah been rolling looking forward
to seeing what I can do
are you know I'm gonna do for our
Houston Chama bust out the old pictures
and post to Instagram you know we just
started rolling well that's why I did
that what that ice bucket challenge I
mentioned 315 yeah we done Venice Beach
yeah a beach dude remember we did our
first firing the kid people don't
realize this would ya at the UFC Expo we
did there when they were nice to me but
then remember when we did uh actually
the Santa Monica Performance Center
appear yes and no one who we were and we
were just we have mics and we're sitting
on the couch yeah it's such a nightmare
I don't know how the [ __ ] they talked us
into is like this is gonna be the next
biggest thing and we go there we both
knew it was gonna be like
not so it was so strange yeah it was
really [ __ ] weird there's no like we
and we we came in hot came here was in
suits yes it was such a weird thing it
really truly was
but you remember we used to wheel oh
that's at the UFC Fan Expo yeah I was I
had very tight jeans on I think I was
having trouble they look a bit tight
that was the quest guys that's where I
met those quest guys huh yeah Oh see
this one that's the first one Wow
is it ever dude you get our mics they
kill young how long ago is that [ __ ] man
seven years ago eight years ago is that
true has to be really has to be come on
back think about coming the closing
party so we were next
he started it was middle of the day it
was some [ __ ] like is that like 1 a.m. 1
p.m. on a weekday oh it's a Wednesday
afternoon look nobody do a podcast on
why 1 2 3 4 5 there's six people in the
car social media week and you're
laughing look at let's see this you want
to watch it I mean a little bit social
media we has system that's listen to it
clapping oh come on that's crazy talk
alright yeah
he's big in person is me they are they
recording right now can they hear us I
think so
hey that's fantastic it's gonna be
awkward if we're like this far apart do
I that's nothing we host this kind of us
in the cha thanks guys for coming this
is this you shouldn't have does anybody
work here or there so we have nothing at
all we just whoa
say exactly and I chose to buy a house
there and so but we took the inside and
redid it - can you imagine off that
progress chain you have to watch it do
you imagine going to that and not known
who we are just sitting there like hey
dude I like Alabama a whole two [ __ ]
bullshit's great yeah well some moss
root and shirt that's right yeah Fox
freakin was like you need to do this we
know that was great well listen I did
our thing buddy here we are yeah we are
so funny man
would you ever think about shaving your
head again now that you've seen a
husband no I was I was gonna do it with
Tiger it was mom one Kenneth here really
he smells so good whatever your your
lady does to him she sprays him or
something oh he's such a little cutie
pie so [ __ ] dude we're playing with
water balloons yesterday they have a
thing now I'm sure have you guys seen
this I know it's talking about so when I
was a kid you'd get the balloon you put
it on the faucet you turn it it fill up
and you tie it off hope you didn't break
this little bastard has a thing you just
put on there it fills up 25 yeah all at
once my kids and it wants to fall off
automatically and then we just [ __ ]
throw them at each other whip it at each
other my kids that's their favorite game
their favorite game well Tiger might
show them a thing he would throw at me
at bounce laughs oh dude look at take
the balloon and smack down my head so
whenever game over you just stood by
then kept going and then he couldn't
break it and it was all he did he's a
very rough trial run kid like he's a
roughhouser you know some kids like my
son is the exact opposite of that and
he's just my son is like me he sees a
thin boy he's just tall and skinny and
Tiger is built for just
you know to run into things and and it's
funny how it reflects it is it his neck
have you ever seen him yeah he's giant
his neck though he's like he's naturally
just all muscle at four years old I've
never seen like videos check up this is
it with the balloons looks like a
crossfitter for real he's got sloped
shoulders at four you're like what and
Boston's even bigger yeah we have a
picture it was heads bigger than yours
his head's bigger dick bigger but he
he's got a piece you got chase he got
uncle juice being so Jay so Tiger think
wow Mike sticker but stay at five months
old with a picture of Tigers foot which
is like this and the Boston's like oh
wow it's gonna be huge
he's me my offense tackle Wow probably
gets paid that's amazing yeah maybe yeah
I don't care what they do something
educational yeah zoom in well see they
come through him tried to break that
balloon it's not eating right now it's
even slow-motion trying to break these
that's all you did I bought balloons I
wanted to get him excited with these
water balloons and then we're playing
he's a guy this is finally go dude check
this out and I take the blue like this
then he's like oh yeah I'm just gonna do
that with all the balloons so was me
filling up they see a hundred balloons
to him smashed it on his head like
that's not fun for anybody else my
grandpa's here your grandma's here boss
like my son sneezed on me yesterday and
goes at Kinnick coronavirus I was like
you little son of a [ __ ] got that [ __ ]
all the juice didn't [ __ ] games to get
that all oh [ __ ] yeah that rotisserie
for the [ __ ] now we can go in that's
it's open we can actually go in and get
our food she don't think we can sit down
yet nobody can take it outside in yeah
you wanna sit in there it's a good [ __ ]
[ __ ] chillin yeah take it outside
look at I did you want me to video
explore motion breaking it never broke
them dude I didn't get I'm did people
respond well to my parkour in slow
motions that was beautiful honey
seventy-five balloons ladies and
gentlemen yeah this all he does the
entire time in the backyard whole time
the whole time
I'll tell you who's a look at the
healthy
it's hilarious what I see a guy running
down the street with a scarf around his
thing and all muscle and I'm like that
dudes in shape
it was our boy Jeff Foley oh yeah
[ __ ] how about the hair on that get
easy shape I know and and when you see
him with a shirt off you there's nothing
to be mad at this how old are you 40 47
47 if I can you know now you won't see I
don't think I don't think even bring him
up I don't know if we want to bring him
up with this no it's all good you know
anything he's gonna pop up it's okay
okay now he's the investment guy he's
not moving looking all right just
obscure no manager sure okay first is a
sad one actor Fred Willard died who's so
much older than I thought I went out
with him I work with Fred a couple times
let it be um came remember honestly
lunch stuff yeah he was just so funny
well I remember him and uh so good in
the [ __ ] you know got was it Everybody
Loves Raymond no I didn't want to not
really know but I watch that stuff I'm
Ron Burgundy
oh man yeah Boston Inkerman we're gonna
have let you go so funny yeah cause of
death hasn't been determined yet when I
was was 86 so I can imagine a number of
including Khurrana yeah they might check
it was grown yeah
wow what a Korea's got Marc Maron's
lifetime or granola mm-hmm Marc Maron
what didn't get that when this happen uh
you have Marc Maron's girlfriend died Oh
God and he talked about on the podcast
use I don't know what else to do the
side deal with grieving I can't believe
know me as this um yeah so he yes she
died she had a rare blood disorder
he said she thought she had threats
strep throat yeah so she got that taken
care of and then he chews at his house
and she went to go to the bathroom it
was like in the middle of night she fell
down and they realized like she was in
shock so he called the cops he said last
thing that was at whatever midnight
12:45 and they took her away and then he
she passed away at the hospital mmm I
gotta call him yet and stuff oh I'm so
sorry about that
I didn't know that um let me see her was
she an actress she's a writer director
did some movies learn more shows
together
yeah it's a big time writer he watch his
uh his podcast he talked about it he's
like you I finally found something I
connected with and we'd write her half
it's like such a shame such a shame
she's a smoke show too man she was mad
she looked at 54 well that's very son
really really super pretty damn it yeah
mark was like I finally found love I
never had it before
such a shame that's heartbreaking they
use I price even be doing this podcast
but this is this is all I know how to
deal with grieving so that's why I'm
doing it ah yeah I guess she came on
years ago on his podcast I've never met
before and she was friends with his
ex-wife so he's always a little like
it'll be about bring her on and then he
brought her on and he said there's she
was married at the time he had a
girlfriend but he said there's ass weird
instant connection between them like
Ryder went right away like instant love
he's like he's so strange and then she
got divorced he separated girl they got
together mm-hmm
so sad man Wow I know such a bummer
it's so weird with death because all you
can do is say I'm sorry you know I'm
just kind of yeah yeah I don't know you
know she had a kid too I don't know how
old he is but a blood disorder
ain't that a [ __ ] yeah yep feel for
mark man I love mark man
what else we got what you guys got well
on Saturday there was an explosion that
happened in downtown LA close to Little
Tokyo and 11 firefighters ended up being
very badly injured
there was an explosion they don't know
exactly what caused the explosion but it
was so bad that it started raining ash
everywhere downtown and didn't melt the
melt the firefighters helmets do it when
the anti start melting there and why
you're so intense it had really really
terrible injuries and they don't know if
it was like a plan or they don't they
don't know yep scary though man so so in
this video I used to live like two three
blocks away from here oh holy oh my god
ash is raining four blocks huh scary
good it sounds crazy so are they all
they're all in critical condition or
what last I I think there were a few of
them that are currently in critical
condition I don't know if anyone has
passed away as of today supposedly
there's a video of them but firefighters
walking out of the flash was down the
ladder as the flames are going up it
must be pretty badass
how about so hot when they're going in
their helmets start melting cuz I guess
they went in originally and then it more
explosions happen they said that as they
were going in it was it there was
something about the explosion that
wasn't very routine with the fire and
that's the reason why they weren't able
to it's like you charged into burning
buildings well yeah what else you guys
got okay so this one's a little more
lighthearted
a lot more lighthearted but there has
been a spike in people buying these like
virtual reality headsets since the stea
home shelter has been put into place and
there's this specific program where you
basically put on the headset and it
looks like you're walking on like the
ledge the edge of a building and so what
you're supposed to do is put like a
block of wood in front of the person
with
head set and then you walk straight down
following and this is a video of a
person yeah so it seems like you're
gonna fall it's so cool I can't do that
[ __ ] makes me [ __ ] you know what I be
do you so into it I gotta sam harris on
his podcast had a guy who is a physicist
or whatever and he was talking about the
nature of reality and he said we may
need to go beyond the space-time
continuum and it might be that we are
living in this like yes simulation yeah
yeah weird that you know I mean it's
just so [ __ ] weird that what why does
that guy think that jumping I have no
idea it's so funny [ __ ] fine focus TV
that's how we were like what the [ __ ]
why are you chopped into the TV what's
what's blow guy oh this is just people
[ __ ] up let's see let's watch it I
love this [ __ ] yeah I don't mess with
virtual reality a lot of people use it
for the VR porn - hmm really well no
that works must lose your salon
no no oh that was bricked it was like
yeah I'm gonna get it that is so bad so
a lot of people gonna get hurt and die
probably don't do it that'll get that's
brick
yeah it's brick that doesn't give on at
least she had that to come roll down
below that at least she had a head
it's just our games yeah all right
that's hilarious
all right mine are not that great it's
very tough to find some stuff here but
listen all right let's take a look at ya
this priest shootin holy water what the
squirt gun I totally because of
distancing that's great and a
drive-through fantastic experience
squirt yeah that's one these uh guys
have a couple that are kind of cool this
one was from SportsCenter
and that girl is at CJ print t24 yeah
just hit the rim a certain way that's
right bashes her head oh yeah and this
was the coolest one I've seen so far
have you seen this that praying mantis
[ __ ] up a lizard yeah but look how it
happens - so this is real with two L's
underscore nature Instagram check it out
you think can view some dogs the lizard
tries to eat the praying mantis but the
praying mantis ends up grabbing the
lizard's head and starts eating its face
you can always see a little bossy little
pecks the lizard Wow yes the lizards
like what when the lizard fight I don't
know
why didn't he take off it looks like
it's one of his hands inside that lizard
I probably like just oh there he goes
tell me takes him off yeah oh look at
his mouth ah dude oh I [ __ ] his jaw
low
yeah oh he keeps going at him I didn't
see it this far goddamn lizard he could
have got away dude I didn't eat your
[ __ ] eyeball Bunch
mantises are [ __ ] game yeah gangster
oh my god
are you eating his eyeballs oh man
they're awful this lizards just taking
it doing little pieces - I mean that's
not how you want to die oh yeah we'll
see you later hate the whole [ __ ]
that's probably what I mean that's awful
I get it what the lizard was gonna you
know yeah just listen they don't [ __ ]
around always a strong go don't kill him
artists are gangster man but then if you
see one like in a but you if you kill
you you know they're cool if you if you
walk around look at them now much bigger
than yeah but lizard they're like this
to get close to me that penis if that
thing was looks like a monster the
monster faces you don't want to get
eaten that's not good lizard but dude
run buddy
all right one last funny one
it's a baking tutorial I mean that's you
could make it [ __ ] oh did you watch the
finale of Last Dance I say nope
that's good I've seen last night you saw
the finale the last dance Oh No yeah my
dude what a Michael Jordan documentary
oh I'm so first - I gotta watch I can't
get that I can't get
[Music]
I tried for it
we did not give me a chill everything
gun no no no I'll watch now watching us
I just gotta get it how do you uh yelled
in that text here I go I can't [ __ ]
fine figure it out Frank goes where are
they send it now I couldn't find it dude
what's this one real quick
it's Guadalajara Mexico yeah yes please
thumb is loose the guitar gets loosened
the way they try to grab him is pretty
interesting
ah I hope that's his time to tell these
people feel safe in the car so they're
chasing it down and there these guys
have lassos cowboy hats
check out the blocking room yeah this
[ __ ] chair oh [ __ ] why I watch the
tire Oh got him oh oh the tiger just
puts up with it when they put that rope
sorry dude you're a tiger turn right now
I'm up and yeah yeah he's able to
blossom yeah it's pretty chill tiger
yeah yeah local house oh Mexico
Guadalajara oh sure that's what my girls
run that's their hometown there you go
and that is pretty much it everything
else's I think we covered a lot there
yeah yeah I think we did buddy we did it
next week Houston pal Houston buddy I'm
excited it's all sold out or I'm
Holden's actually open up more capacity
so I think there's you mean more tickets
available oh that's beautiful yeah I
know we were yeah I know we're supposed
to add shows that you guys and shows
yeah I thought we were to let me click
on it gin mm-hmm pretty sure so things
just sold out and hopefully they open up
more seeds
okay and then I just spoke in still
there that things almost so click on
spoken as his soda Salt Lake City's July
16th through the 18th my dumbass posted
eighteen through twenty it's actually
July 16th through the 18th in Salt Lake
City Utah wise guys those takers just
went on sale yesterday and then spoke in
seems like there's a couple almost sold
out so yet
June 25th through the 27th get your
tickets now to fat K calm yeah so we had
spoken
we had it Salt Lake City and we ran some
more stuff I'll see you guys next week
in Houston and Thicke boy bike club
merch available at Thicke boy calm
anything else be that's it Bob all right
man this fine kid we're out